this is the hope hostel in kigali it's
got a hundred bedrooms
which are going to house asylum seekers
coming from the uk they're all double
bedrooms and they've all been set up and
made ready for when they do come to
rwanda this is one of the bedrooms here
which you can have a look at it's been
made ready the beds have been laid out
there's a table in the corner as well
and there's a table of amenities as well
which is obviously for when they arrive
they're trying to make it as comfortable
as possible there are also some slippers
down here which they'll they'll be
putting on um well they'll be offered to
put on as well there's a view of kagali
out of the window and this is a place
which is interesting because i've been
here before but when i was here there
wasn't all of the arabic signage that
was in april but in the couple of months
in between it's quite clear they've
started thinking about asylum seekers
who are from arabic countries and how
they can accommodate them so that means
there's a prayer room in here there are
also signs everywhere in arabic halal
food is also offered